it's Michael Kosta leaves he was born
1943 in Aberdeen United Kingdom and he
graduated with his PhD from Oxford
University in 69 and he is presently the
Harrison Farnsworth professor of physics
at Brown University in the United States
and I know that he has Nordic
connections visit Sweden and yes also a
close connection to physics Institute in
Finland so professor consulates have
given many crucial contributions to the
theory of phase transitions should
mention in particular the cost elites
renormalization group equations that
have been very influential in many in
many areas of physics not only the phase
transitions in two-dimensional materials
that we will hear about but also as was
alluded to in the lecture by Professor
Hall Dane that there is a very deep and
intriguing connection between classical
physics in two dimensions in quantum
mechanics in one dimensions and the
costal it's renormalization group
equations and the costly stylus phase
transition has been instrumental for
understanding also quantum properties of
matter professor costal it has been
rewarded the launch on Sagar price and
the maxvill metal and he will now give
the second 2016 the bear lecture in
physics with the title topological
defects and pace transitions this as a
costly
thank you very much whoops good morning
it feels a bit strange to be standing
here addressing this August audience
because I never never thought that I
would ever end up in this position but
here I am so I will do my best to try to
explain how I got to this point I'll
tell you some of the story how I got
here and the particular pay homage to
the man who really started me off in
this field
David Fowler's now see if I can get my
computer to work okay so there the early
work of David which was very influential
or to our thinking in this field he did
in a very short physical review paper
back in 1969 it was incredibly short
just two sides of a piece of paper I
remember rightly and it was basically
related to a simple model it was just a
one-dimensional magnetic Ising magnet
with a Hamiltonian written written up
there the first line and depended on
with different ranges interaction ranges
okay so it was known that if the
interaction range was longer than one
over the square of the distance between
between spins that there was no
magnetization at any temperature and no
phase transition however if the range
interaction area was longer
was also known that there was a
transition finite temperature
the transition to a state of finite
magnetization david was asked he visited
Bell Labs and he was asked did he know
anything about this intermediate
situation or the interaction range was
exactly one over the distance squared
between spins because this was just a
strange situation and nobody really
understood what was going on there
and so according to the story I hear is
that on the way back of the train from
Bell Labs to Stony Brook he had a had an
inspiration and a typical of David
David's inspiration actually rather
simple but extremely deep and now this
is the fascinating thing about David
Thewlis that his his his ideas sound
quite simple but when you sort of think
about the consequences the implications
are what he says you realize wow this
guy really is deep there's a very very
deep thinker so you should never get a
mistake
the simplicity of the ideas with their
and with with the death because it's
often very simple ideas which are the
deepest now so what David simply said
was it's very simple let's think about
the system and imagine there's some my
age it's a low temperatures as
magnetized and let's assume some some
magnetization talking to a Ferro magnet
so it's simple no anti ferromagnetic no
difficulties and oh by the way I should
mention that I am talking in purely
classical but for purely about purely
classical systems and the reason for
this is that
at the time when I got interested in
condensed matter
I knew essentially nothing about the
subject and to me
quantum mechanics just an unnecessary
complication which only half understood
anyway so everything I I'm going to talk
about from now on is purely classical so
then so to come back to the problem
David said all right let's suppose
imagine having a system a magnetized
system now let's simply imagine flipping
a segment of the of this chain of spins
just reversing the spins they're called
these values possible values of the
spins plus one a minus one and every
time you see a plus one spin in this
block change it to minus one and
vice-versa so if you do this the energy
change is given by this little formula
at the bottom of the slide so now the
consequence of this it's just that it's
in this in this special case of one over
one of our distance squared interactions
is that the change in energy is given by
very simple formula it's basically twice
the square root of mine is a sham use
the magnetization here times the
exchange constant times the logarithm of
the size of the block you've decided to
flip fine so then you ask yourself so
what what is the consequence of this
well as you probably know we're in
statistical mechanics which is what
we're trying to do here the essential
quantity that's of interest is the so
called free energy which is just energy
minus temperature times the entropy and
the entropy is nothing other than the
logarithm of the number of possibilities
and the number of possibilities is
simply late
to the number of positions of allowed
positions of the of the reversal and the
number of allowed positions is basically
n the length of the block so the change
in the free energy is just energy minus
temperature times the log times the
entropy and entropy is Boltzmann's
constant this case RB you have to put in
to get the dimensions right and so you
get this little little little formula
written down there now the consequence
of this is if there is long-range order
in other words if it's magnetized then
we must have the coefficient of the
logarithm of the size of the block must
be positive in other words we're talking
about low temperatures where so the
first term must be larger than the
second term in the bracket and then we
expect that act assuming that that that
does undergo of phase transitions with
some a critical temperature called T sub
C that the magaz ation disappears and
what you also it has to happen is this
free energy difference this Delta F has
to go to zero therefore the critical
temperature must be given by the
vanishing of that the coefficient of
lager and the system size so we've got
the formula that twice 2 mu squared J
must be equal to KT C at the critical
temperature and remember the manga's
ation mu is the magnetization
okay now that formula which looks sort
of very trivial very obvious has a
remarkable mark remarkable implications
it means the magnetization must go
discontinuously to zero at the critical
temperature assuming of course the
critical
is positive so now there was a lot of
knowledge and Lord about phase
transitions available at the time and
what this what the subfloor was saying
that and if a at the continuous phase
transition the magnetization should
disappear
smoothly as you approach the critical
temperature from below okay now assuming
this is a continuous transition this is
saying winnaman this formula is saying
wait a minute wait a minute no that
can't happen because the Magnus has got
to jump
discontinuous like two zero as you pass
through the critical temperature this is
actually a very strange result but
because normally one thinks of a phase
transition where the something jumps
this continuously zero is what it's
called the first order transition but
this transition is well known not to be
first order so this is the most unusual
situation again that's very typical of
david he comes up with these very
apparently very simple arguments which
have the most extraordinary consequences
trouble is that there's no way to dis to
argue that its arguments incorrect so
with now we've now if I he now found
something unusual again because he's
found a very very strange situation
where we have a system where we have a
so-called continuous transition but it
has a discontinuous magnetization at the
critical temperature so this is just the
sort of argument which David Thewlis
produced which has some extra you know
extraordinary at the time consequences
certainly correct argument but what
more important from my point of view was
in the work that Dave and I did together
later and I did myself this argument
listen observation was actually very
influent extremely influential now we're
not so let me now tell you a little a
very short story about my how I ended up
at berming I was actually brought up as
a high energy physicist and so it's
really keen on doing the glamorous
high-energy physics stuff and I happened
to be at a postdoc in Italy at at you
know Torino University we think with the
ambition of going on to the standard
place for high-energy physics afterwards
CERN a Geneva but as is my standard
downfall I fail to get my paperwork in
on time so I didn't get it could not get
a spot in in in at CERN and ended up so
jobless so I quickly sent my wife or my
girlfriend at the time down to the
railway station in Torino to buy an
English newspaper where I could look for
some job adverts and apply for apply for
whatever job I could find so now I wrote
out a few applications sent them in and
then got offered a job at as opposed as
a long-term postdoc at Birmingham
University which was to tell the truth
the last place I wanted to go to because
I was determined to go to CERN in Geneva
but it wasn't hot whilst it wasn't to
happen so I ended up in Birmingham and
it did some long tedious calculations
high energy physics for about a year and
they got really really tired of it
because first of all I didn't get
anywhere second I was
just when I was about to write that
stuff up or had written the pre-pre yeah
it's time to write up the preprint then
suddenly I'd go i paper will arrive at
my desk doing exactly what I was doing
and so this happened two or three times
and these calculators don't produce for
some group in Berkeley so after their
second or third time with us I realized
that it wasn't going to work because
here I was on my own
calculate away doing things and every
time I almost was finished the preprint
arrived on my desk so I was clearly not
not in a very strong position here so in
desperation I went around the department
and bring him Birmingham asking begging
people for if they had a problem that
might be tractable perhaps I could look
at it
so eventually ended up in Dave Fowler's
office and I listened to him talking
about introduced him to also the weird
and wonderful new concepts things like
vortices in superfluid helium helium
films and phase transitions in in two
dimensions of course much of this was a
mystery to me because I actually had
skipped statistical mechanics in
graduate school because it didn't seem
to be relevant to my proposed field of
high-energy physics which was a mistake
but and also and I say I was in the in a
place which was the last place I wanted
to go to listening to David explaining
lots of weird wonderful ideas to me
which you could barely understand
however what they was saying made
something a lot of intuitive sense to me
so I thought well maybe this statistical
mechanics stuff he could be quite
interesting so we started you know we
started looking at some of these
two-dimensional systems and the
situation in the early 70s is basically
summarized in it on this slide here and
[Music]
the class is a class of models which
correct which are basically they cover
all of the classical system our VLEs and
they described by a Hamiltonian given up
at the top of the top of the slide there
where we considering a ferromagnetic
model in in two dimensions now not three
where we have got n spins of n
components and we keep the spin like
fixed at one say and so what is what was
known about these models at the time
well not much we saw the only sold model
was the N equals one case spin up or
down although it's known as the two
dimensionalizing model now this was
solved by most extraordinary calculation
by Lars Onsager back in when it was in
in in the 1940s and in this model yes
there is a phase transition we know that
from the exact solution the next set of
next case is two components pens
now the read this isn't this is this was
interesting for physical reasons because
this would describe a model it's a model
for a a thin film of superfluid helium
four and what was known about this
model at the time was well maybe there's
a transition there it might be but who
knows if the number of spin components
is greater than 2 then the simulations
high-temperature series expansions
cetera said they're probably there isn't
a phase transition at any finite
temperature and the only thing that was
really properly known as the limit of
the infinite number of spin components
otherwise known as the spherical model
and an exact solution says this one in
two dimensions has got no transitions so
clearly the situation needed a bit of
further study be particularly because of
the importance of the two component
model which would this could be a
description of superfluid helium films
now there was a piece of experimental
evidence floating around and I show this
picture here it was in a fit of laughter
1972 and this piece of evidence this the
sick piece of experimental evidence
tells us basic under big u ously that
the N equals 2 case does her face
transition because you see this is a
this is an experiment done by Marvin
Chester and coworkers
and consists of looking at the resonant
frequency of of a vibrating crystal and
the absorbed some helium
onto the surface of the crystal and
measured the change in the resonant
frequency now as you all should know the
resonant frequency of some vibrating
object it's inversely proportional to
the map mass because the mass increases
the arresting frequency decreases that's
all you really need to know at this
stage and so they did a set of
experiments and the the dots are the
experimental results the straight line
is what you expect assuming that all the
absorbed helium sticks to the surface
because the the film is so thin that any
atom of healing that gets absorbed in
the surface of the of the of the crystal
assuming that it's a normal forms a
normal fluid like water or something
that would as the crystal moves
backwards or forwards the molecule
absorb more ghosts also move backwards
and forwards and that will increase the
the mass of the oscillating object and
so one would expect that as you increase
put more and more fluid on and the
horizontal axis here is just a form it's
basically a formula which tells you you
know where the it is gives you an exact
measure of the total mass adsorbed onto
the onto the surface of the crystal and
so the initial data when the first few
Bala culs go in followers just expected
straight line you can see that but then
at some point when as you adsorb more
more helium on to this crystal something
very strange happens suddenly there's a
whole you know massive of absorbed
helium suddenly stops doesn't contribute
to the resonant frequency and so one can
argue that the deviation of difference
between the experimental points and the
straight line is a measure of the amount
of superfluid amount of fluid that has
become
decoupled from the crystal and so once
it's decoupled from the crystal what do
you do you wave your hands and call it a
superfluid because it is completely
unexpected okay so this piece of
experimental evidence were staring us in
the face saying that look in this system
- campinas spin - XY z-- this system a
planar rotor a spin system there must in
two dimensions there must be a phase
transition now suddenly there is does
have a transition which contradicts the
standard interpretation at the time of
some rigorous theorems which said that
there is no long-range order in such in
such two-dimensional systems and of
course this rigorous theorem for many
years you know no arguing with rigorous
films absolutely correct but the
interpretation could be argued with
because the interpretation of this
theorem would say there's no phase
transition because of the standard
Landau interpretation that a phase
transition implies that suddenly in the
ordered phase you have long-range order
so here is a situation where there's
clearly a phase transition but there's a
rigorous theorem also says okay
there's no long-range order so the
problem that we were then faced with is
to somehow reconcile these two
apparently contradictory statements
clearly the experiment says look there
is a phase transition there's the data
it's obvious there's a phase transition
that's one that's experimental side the
theoretical side said there's no
long-range order there's no arguing with
the theorem but so the only conclusion
one can come to is that
the the the theorem is correct but it's
not relevant there's certainly a phase
transition now it's just sort of this is
typical David Thewlis problem you know
he could see that there was a
contradiction here that can be you know
should past should be looked at my own
said my own take on the matter at the
time was I don't understand this
so what I you know I didn't know about
these rigorous theorems and so on but it
looked like an interesting problem to
work on so I thought okay why not so we
started looking at it now this slide
sorry it looks so busy but I thought
that I would redraw this thing to make
to make it less busy and but of course
the nobles input Annabel wheat is so so
every moment of every day as is
scheduled for the laureates that there
was no time to do anything so X I
apologize this bit this this overly
overly busy slide now so what do we know
about what what's the situation
first thing as you can we're talking
about superfluid helium or if you like
spin model where two components spin
model where let's say assume that this
length of the spin is fixed so the spin
configuration can be defined by this
angle theta and if you like the
superfluid the superfluid order
parameter is just the S sub X plus I
times S sub y we should be written in
the form amplitude times e to the
you know ETI theta with it as a face now
this whole system is invariant under the
phase shifted by any multiple of 2pi so
therefore we can say that the the global
excitations of the system of the so
called topological excitations are what
are called vortices and this is just a
spin configuration where if you walk
around a contour some closed contour
then the change in the phase as you go
around this closed contour is a multiple
of 2pi and of course has to be a
multiple of 2pi because the order
parameter itself has to be the same when
you come you know if you start somewhere
go around and come back the system had
better be the same thing that you
started with and so this phase this
order parameter which I write as
amplitude times e to the I theta that
has to be single valued and so therefore
the change of phases go around the
contour come back to where you started
must be a multiple of 2pi bazap leaves
the the order parameter itself invariant
however if the change of phase as you go
around some contour is is is one or two
or minus 1 or minus two what that saying
is there must be a singularity in the
order parameter right it somewhere
inside this contour and of course this
sounds a little physical because after
all we're talking about here is a film
of helium adsorbed and some some nice
continuous surface so how on earth can
something be discounted how on earth can
we
have a change of you know a phase change
of 2pi we'll just walk around the circle
well it's very big it's very simple we
say that okay we have got a vortex with
what we've done this we've walked round
a we walked round a vortex say we've
gone round say clockwise and we are
changing the face by two five when we
walk around walk around the psalm some
point in the middle and then we can say
the point in the middle with a blue blob
in the middle is a is the corner of the
vortex and so what happens in the vortex
core is let's say the magnitude of the
order parameter or the just as either
you know it's just zero so in other
words that's if you like it's a hole
it's like a topologically it's like like
a hole in in in the surface so of course
one can have a contour running around a
hole where the phase change can be two
pilots nothing wrong with that no see
when go back okay now let's go back a
little bit ask what's the what are the
consequence of this well suppose we just
make the argument let's consider a large
system and let's consider an isolated
vertex just put an isolated vortex in
the system and let's calculus it's an L
by L system the energy of an isolated
vertex in the system
it's just proportional to the logarithm
of the system size as long L over a
where a is some microscopic cut off like
a lattice spacing or the vortex core
size something like that the entropy
change and the entropy associate of this
vortex is simply Boltzmann's constant to
get dimensions right time
the logarithm of the number of possible
positions of the vortex the vortex core
and of course the number of possible
positions is just the total area of the
system divided by the area of a vortex
cord because that's the number of
possible places you can put the vortex
and so we you then get that the free
energy is e minus temperature times the
entropy
so again you get this logarithm the
logarithmic formula a little bit like
what we have in the in the
one-dimensional one over R squared Isaac
model and so you can then just say okay
the central quantity in statistical
mechanics is the free energy so the
associate of free energy is just a minus
temperature the entropy so there's your
two formulas for the entry energy and
the entropy you just plug that in and
then you can say the probability of such
a configuration or if you like having a
vortex is nice it's a statistical
mechanics again so I assume you have to
know some of our mechanics and it's just
proportional to the exponential of minus
sorry I've written beta by beta mean 1
over Boltzmann's constant times
temperature eat the minus beta F and you
have a formula for the free energy and
so the probability of a vortex is the
system size divided by the microscopic
cutoff like the core diameter or
something like that the power of minus
PI K minus 2 where K is just the
exchange constant divided by Boltzmann's
constant times temperature so in other
words K is a temperature dependent
quantity which is large at low
temperatures and smalls at high
temperatures and so this little formula
here that the probability of having a
vortex and isolated vortex
the system is L of Ray what l over is a
huge number
^ pi K minus 2 for K as a quantity that
is inversely proportion in the
temperature so in other words this
probability of a vortex being present is
0 if PI K is greater than 2 you know as
long as the exponent the power is
positive is negative that means at low
temperatures the probability of having a
vortex is 0 and higher temperatures this
probability when PI K is less than 2
there's probability as we want okay of
course I've I've forgotten about other
other normalization of that formula and
so on but let's forget about these
little little details here so in other
words this system should have a
transition around the temperature such
that this factor this this this K was a
temporary measure is a measure the
temperature is larger than 2 of a PI now
that is the essential argument of our
original paper which was published way
back when and 797 273 and we can say
that when this this temperature
dependent coupling constant K is is
large the topological sector in other
words this the number of vortices was
the problem to create a thermally
creating a vortex is 0 at high
temperatures then the top allure you can
say this single topological sector the
number of orders won't change because
there's a huge energy barrier to get
over
it has to be stable whereas when the
temperatures high on alternative dispara
this temperature dependent parameter K
is small then there can be transitions
between different topological sectors
and of course what this in turn means is
that in principle at low temperatures
you should have a superfluid but at high
temperatures you want simply because so
let's see why that should happen okay
now let me just okay let's think about a
superfluid for a moment to let born is a
superfluid let's suppose that the super
fool lives between those two vertical
blueish lines I'm sorry these slides are
not that good it's because I had to make
them all myself
and I'm not the greatest artist I have
to use whatever is available on the
little program so this is the best that
could do now in a superfluid this is a
system line between those two vertical
lines let's suppose we've got a system
where we've got a uniform flow in a
downward direction with velocity u s-- u
sub s that's that's the super fluid
velocity how can this decay because if
this if if this cannot this flow cannot
be dissipated then we have a super fluid
if it can be dissipated it's a normal
fluid and the only possible way of doing
this of dissipating the super fluid flow
is to create a vortex an t vortex pair
and see if they just simply drift
further and further apart and if we can
get infinitely far apart if you like
they go to the system edges and
disappear poof and in this process they
will unwind the face and and reduce the
super fluid velocity slightly
so this is the central question now if
you're at high temperatures these
vortices can be produced
you know appear spontaneously and in
large numbers so this process will
easily occur because this super fluid
flow would simply cause the vortices to
disappear to the sides and the super
fluid velocity will go to zero all right
so what does this mean this means that
the fluid is normal because remember
equilibrium statistical mechanics is
always talking about if you like the
infinite time limit so it doesn't care
what happens at short times short times
being is any mathematical time less than
infinity it doesn't matter if things
take longer than the age of the universe
to happen but in equilibrium system of
mechanics once not doesn't care about
timescales so at high temperatures
because of the possibility of creating
these vortices clearly the superfluid
any super fluid flow has to be
dissipated by this mechanism I just
talked about at low temperatures on the
other hand the probability of getting if
an isolated free vortex which can drift
under the influence of a super fluid
uniform superfluid velocity they don't
exist and therefore you have to call
that a superfluid this flow will be
matters at least metastable so at least
now we've got a mechanism for
distinguishing between a superfluid and
a normal fluid and the therefore the
next thing we had to study was a system
of vortices which is you know you may
say this all right I could of course
give you the formula for the energy of a
of some complexion of vortices and say
we do this Fitness through mechanics of
this but that formula is so disgustingly
complicated and it's probably longer
than I could write down and in this
PowerPoint slide so I won't even attempt
to do it but it can be done however now
David and I cooked up a theory which
involved remember now here we've got a
set of point vortices which interact log
logarithmically now for those of you who
have actually done electrodynamics in in
arbitrary dimensions you will
immediately recognize this logarithm as
a Coulomb interaction between charges so
one could guard the vortices as a set of
point charges interacting with the
Coulomb interaction and so then of
course once you've got this you
immediately think ah
dielectric functions etc etc etc and so
one could think of the system in terms
of an electrostatic theory and this is
basically what Dave and I did at least
rather let's say well it Dave and I did
back in 1972-73 and that paper is
probably the most cited paper either
either of us have ever written and it is
basically a correct but in our
calculations we unfortunately made an
incorrect an unfortunately unnecessary
simplification which best everything up
and that calculation has since been
strained out strained now for 979 or so
by Peter Young who basically redid our
calculation in a in a correct manner
and pointed out the error that we we had
made but also I was bothered about the
results of our calculation because the
results didn't look right let me just I
had a bad feeling about them so I
thought okay maybe I should try to do a
proper calculation here and use this
thing which was just appearing called
the renormalization group of course I
actually learnt the renormalization
group from paper which David had kindly
given me by Phil Anderson
Gideon you've all done harm on where he
talked about the one over R squared
isaac model in in the context of the
condo problem which was all the rage
those days and i spent about six months
doing nothing but reading and rereading
this paper so we've got 0 minutes left
okay so so eventually we got some
results so here are the results of my of
my renormalization group calculation now
what this this for this calculation says
is that it actually makes some
prediction so one it makes a prediction
of is the this the Ray the superfluid
density at just below TC as a function
of the critical temperature and what is
interesting about this little curve this
little diagram is that the the
theoretical curve is that straight line
which is the theoretical prediction the
experiment the various dots are
experiments and according to Mike John
Rafi apparently the dots were all
plotted before the without knowledge
of the theory and then when the when
they learned about the theory just put
the straight line in and to the great
astonishment it went basically right
through the the the experimental dots
and so one could guard this as excellent
confirmation of of the of the theory so
and this is basically the reason why our
theory has become quite well-known which
actually works and has been measured and
verified in many systems none of course
by me I wish I had done it but it had so
I bet I better stop there and thank in
particular the Nobel Committee for
awarding a surprise and my wife and
children putting up with me thank you
[Applause]
so thank you very very much for this
inspiring lecture and in particular I
hope that all graduate students in the
audience listened so they might think a
little bit
what is interesting and not interesting
and what is useful and what is not
useful in your further studies and now I
will ask all the three laureates to come
up on the scene please
just keep you
[Applause]